serais-tu prêt à porter l'uniforme pour
aller au collège et au lycée c'est ce
qu'a annoncé aujourd'hui Gabriel Attal
le ministre de l'éducation nationale le
jour de la rentrée scolaire dès cet
automne à la Toussaint le ministre
détaillera les modalités
d'expérimentation en France le port de
l'uniforme dans les collèges et lycées a
disparu après la crise étudiante de 1968
en revanche à l'école primaire il n'a
jamais été obligatoire les élèves
portent et simplement une blouse pour se
protéger de l'encre de leur plume
aujourd'hui pourtant plusieurs
établissements publics l'imposent encore
comme les lycées militaires et
l'internat d'excellence de sourdes c'est
dans les départements d'outre-mer que le
port de l'uniforme est très courant
notamment en Martinique ou un tiers des
établissements l'imposent pareil en
Guadeloupe de la maternelle au bac ainsi
qu'en Guyane en métropole plusieurs élus
se sont déjà dit favorables ericsiotti
députés des Alpes-Maritimes Louis Aliot
le maire de Perpignan ou encore Robert
Ménard le maire de Béziers mais les mers
n'ont pas le droit d'imposer le port de
l'uniforme ils peuvent simplement le
suggérer l'annonce du ministre de
l'éducation nationale est donc une étape
supplémentaire Brigitte Macron aussi
c'était déjà dit pour le port de
l'uniforme à l'école selon la première
dame l'uniforme gomme les différences
sociales et permet de gagner du temps
car ces chronophages de choisir comment
s'habiller le matin et de l'argent par
rapport aux marques le lendemain le 12
janvier qu'une proposition de loi du
groupe rassemblement national sur le
port de l'uniforme était rejeté à
l'Assemblée nationale
[Musique]